when we treat
dei
like a finite goal
which i think unfortunately too many
companies are
um
and
uh
here's the here's the uncomfortable
reality of all of this stuff
right which is to truly
make improvement and fix things
or at least improve things
it's a it's a steady sometimes slow
process it's like rebuilding trust in a
relationship it doesn't happen with one
bouquet of flowers and a really nicely
written card even if it's really
heartfelt and important and necessary
it's it's consistency and ongoing right
but at the same time we need to see
gestures so that we can see remember we
love a metric we love to see that
something's happening but we see it all
over the place we see it in police
reform we see it in dei we see a lot of
companies and communities doing the
short term stuff for show
that may or may not be having the impact
they need to have i'm okay with the
short term stuff for show so long as the
difficult slow work is happening behind
the scenes simultaneously right um and
so and and great companies as we said
like like good people they and by the
way there's there's no competitors in
the infinite game because you can't beat
anybody there's only other players
right the only true competitors yourself
how do we become a better version of
ourselves today than we were yesterday
and so all of these things
um you know george floyd the murder of
george floyd forced our nation to hold a
mirror up to ourselves and and just to
go as an aside you know
after
floyd is murdered i called um
some of my african-american friends and
i needed advice how to have difficult
conversations i needed i wanted to hear
how they how they were you know
and on some of the conversations i was
crying
and i asked them
there's some things happened with
with all of them i said
i'm crying how come you're not crying
and they said because i'm exhausted
they said this is new for you this is
not new for me this is i live this life
you're just seeing it for the first time
because the whole scene was captured
we've been talking about this but
usually you just see the dead body in
the street we don't see what led up to
it what made george floyd important was
the camera
that we got to see it
and for for people who haven't seen that
for for for all the reasons
it was
shocking
good
you know
um and so i think that when we talk
about the infinite gaming about a
constant improvement
you know
blaming some someone for something they
didn't see
isn't helpful but now that they've seen
it we say okay
let's do that work and let's go through
the constant improvement like what are
the things that we can do inside our
company so this is not for show and
temporary and fashionable
but this becomes part of our
part of our part of our growth part of
who we are
that we become more aware of these
things we have systems in place we have
different kinds of metrics we have
different kinds of incentives we have
different kinds of practices we have
we've implemented things like listening
skills
we've implemented things like teaching
anybody who gets promoted to any
position of leadership to learn how to
have a difficult conversation the
reality is if you can have a difficult
conversation about race you can have a
difficult conversation about anything
your performance is not doing so great
that's a difficult conversation
so i think this is a massive opportunity
like any learning opportunity for
personal growth and companies go through
personal growth like people go through
personal growth